a program for Nevada prisoners going
terribly wrong so much so some inmates
say they were hurt now the state is
being sued and taxpayers could be on the
hook one woman who is one of the inmates
sat down for an exclusive interview with
eight news now investigator Vanessa
Murphy
these are photos of boots worn by Nevada
inmates to help clean up after a fire
you can see they're not in great shape
and a heads up for what their feet
looked like after blisters from what
they say are burns from walking on hot
Embers and soil for hours when you're
behind those walls you're not a person
no more you're a number and that's how
we truly felt this is one of seven
plaintiffs represented by the ACLU suing
the state of Nevada Department of
Corrections and division of Forestry she
served time for child abuse and was
released last July the ACLU asked us not
to reveal her identity in part to not
jeopardize her employment since she is a
convicted felon she and the other
plaintiffs in Florence McClure women's
prison had agreed to participate in a
program for a dollar an hour according
to the ACLU fight fires a lot of us
dealt with drug addiction in the past
violence in relationships you know just
you know
not very good self-confidence this
pushing ourselves to the limits I can do
this I can do this was basically just
building us you know for the outside
and on the inside she says it meant more
privileges little more freedom at Gene
Conservation Camp rather than being
locked up all day but the ACLU calls
training dangerously deficient so we
went through testing physical and paper
wise as far as that you know there's no
training on how to be on a fire on April
20th 2021 The Call for Duty I think that
adrenaline of us oh my God we're here
um
we can do this you know we're strong
cleanup of a fire near Laughlin any fear
after I started feeling like like I
couldn't walk
that's what was my career she claims she
told her crew boss her feet felt raw and
they brushed her off I kind of just
trusted them to know you know that's not
their first fire but as the day went on
I kind of realized there was something
wrong and it just it became myself and
then someone else and then someone else
she says they were warned if they quit
they'd lose their privileges finally the
next day when the crew was supposed to
be heading back to the fire and she says
she just physically couldn't that's when
prison staff realized something was
wrong he kind of jumped into action oh
my God you have you have Burns
um the lieutenant came in was panicked
asked if anybody else was her and I was
like yeah my whole crew she says no
ambulance was called but after what felt
like a long wait they were taken to UMC
and treated the Inspector General
investigated and cited second-degree
burns on the inmate's feet that the
oldest boots were from 2013 and one of
them had a melted off heel they should
be given a compensation for what they
ended up facing atar hazibullah is the
executive director of the ACLU of Nevada
I know some folks are going to say well
you know they were in they were in
prison they should not have compensation
that's a silly argument they didn't sign
up to to basically have their feets
burned and torched in this manner the
Nevada Department of Corrections is now
limiting its fire Crews citing a lack of
staff and inmates who qualify while the
fight in court over these Burns may just
be getting started Vanessa Murphy 8 News
Now